I mean g-dub's and I'm a little hoarse
jeaious right now maybe a horse horse
jeaious because I sling din last night
against my well anyways yeah AG gums on
Twitter um might know me from some of
the pool talks I don't work anywhere
right now
so I'm just going to introduce myself as
somebody who makes mistakes and these
things happen all the time and this suck
depending on how you think about it
could be about making mistakes but I'm
not gonna like tread on this too much
further some mistakes were made you know
we understand this uh but yeah let's
talk about cows in space right cuz what
is my talk even about like does anyone
even know I don't even know right Kazon
space huh maybe that's some over here
for we're here maybe to talk about art
right this is some great art that I
found on the Internet uh yeah I know I
know I'm a bummer you have to talk about
JavaScript yeah and if we're going to
talk actually a little bit about es6
2015 and i'm not going to say that whole
thing every time because I think it's
garbage I'm just going to say es6 and if
you think I'm wrong I don't really care
so anyways let's talk about es6 but you
know it's actually so I'm gonna have to
talk about something else and the first
thing I really want to talk to you about
is abstraction alright and this wouldn't
be a good computer talk if I wasn't you
know going to quote some Dijkstra for
you alright so here we go the effective
exploitation of his powers of
abstraction bummer on the pronoun oh no
no must be regarded as one of the most
vital activities of a competent
programmer and so I take this to mean
that when we're thinking about
programming when we're really doing
programming the behavior that we are
doing is abstracting and it's like okay
abstract is a pretty abstract concept so
let's talk about the abstraction
principle in another really big tome
called types and programming languages
you might have heard of it as Tapley
Benjamin C Pierce defines the
abstraction principle as each
significant piece of functionality in a
program should be implemented in just
one place in this
source code where similar functions are
carried out by a distinct pieces of code
it is generally beneficial to combine
them into one by abstracting out the
varying parts and so this probably is
something that we all do in our daily
lives is potentially one of the things
that we find most satisfying when we
program when we can finally refactor
something into this one elegant function
and that's really really excellent all
right but I want us to understand
abstraction on a theoretical level and
so in order to do the theoretical part
of abstraction I went to Wikipedia and
got this so it's pretty good abstraction
tries to factor out details from a
common pattern so the programs can work
close to the level of human thought
leaving out details which matter in
practice but are immaterial to the
problem being solved and this is
something I want to flag for us the idea
of something being immaterial to the
problem being solved we know as
programmers that one of the big things
that we also do is define the problem
we're solving and so this is something
that's kind of tying that in and I want
is just to kind of flag that so I'm
going to take us on another little
adventure before you know I get to that
whole es6 jumbo so I had the pleasure of
working at the New York City web
development fellowship in its flagship
year and it's a bootcamp program for
people who are unemployed or make very
little money to take them in six months
from basically no programming experience
to being a junior developer there are
problems with some of these programs but
this one was awesome and they are all
there and there are students in mind in
this audience and I'm super proud that
they're here so yeah one of the reasons
I love teaching and you know some people
are like you know if you can do if you
can't teach I think that's real garbage
and so when I say I teach beginners
beginners teach me and a lot of the
lessons that are learned that I want to
share with you in this talk are from
interfacing with beginners on a regular
basis all right so something that I
learned when I was teaching is like for
beginners iteration is really hard I was
right before I started I was at this
Ruby user meetup and the Dean of the
school was giving a talk and he was like
a look at Ruby Ruby is so awesome you
know even your mom could understand that
Ruby array sidebar don't say that stuff
moms are smart and cool don't be rude
anyways so yeah he was like yeah
JavaScript yeah people don't understand
JavaScript he didn't understand that's
also a problem but he has this point
that's actually like kind of core and
really cool and so you might recognize
these excellent hand gesture people here
Abel Simmons Sussman they wrote a book
that we're going to talk about a little
later but what they say in that book is
programs must be written for people to
read and only incidentally for machines
to execute and this is a really big
point people write programs people read
programs the computers do stuff over
there
all right we're really here to program
for people and that's something that we
need to remember but there's a little
bit of a trick here because what does it
mean to write programs for people to
read people really struggle with
instructions sometimes this is a picture
of my door in my Cool Ranch um anyways
yeah so yeah this is this is the
struggle sometimes what does it mean we
don't we don't really know like what
level of objection is good for people to
read alright so we go back into
iteration is hard and this is like a
really neat lesson I met so this array
dot each like I had this sinking feeling
but it he's saying yeah I people could
read it Ruby's great it's interestingly
enough written in English by a Japanese
person anyways um so yeah I was like
okay this is not working everyone is
having a lot of trouble with iteration
this is supposed to be easy what's going
on and so I'm sitting at my desk one day
and my co-teacher blake he's teaching
iteration and ruby to the group for the
first time and I'm kind of like
listening in and it's not going well
it's like just not working and it's that
because Blake's a bad teacher picks
awesome but a cure this and I'm like I
really should jump in what am I gonna do
and I did something kind of bold which
if anyone knows me isn't not a character
uh I was like I'm getting a hijack of
this class and so I walk up into the
class I'm like hey guys I have an idea
and I'm not sure it will work
I have an inkling that it might what I'd
like to do is I'd like to just throw
away all the Ruby you just learned and I
just want to teach you iteration in a
language that you don't know and I think
it's going to work I think you'll
understand and people are like that does
not sound like a good idea
I said yeah no no no Ruby here however
JavaScript was awesome for teaching
iteration because it expressed the
underlying concepts if we look at it
here I mean I know all of us maybe don't
like writing all this syntax out I'll
get to that later but when we understand
iteration it's state condition increment
I see it right there
but in that Ruby it's not and so it was
really really cool that I was able to be
like hey this is the stuff you need to
understand it conceptually and that's
exposed by the language and you can use
this language to teach it and we didn't
teach any more JavaScript for another
like three months but we went back to
Ruby it was fine we use JavaScript as a
teaching tool and so that's like a
really interesting thing to think about
and so I think about a quote from my
secret boyfriend here there's like a
really excellent physics professor
richard fineman
um he says this and this is kind of a
mouthful but I think it's very
interesting he says the real problem in
speech is not precise language the
problem is clear language it is actually
really quite impossible to say anything
with absolute precision unless that
thing is so abstracted from the real
world as not to represent any real thing
and so this I think really pulls out the
conflict we have of when we're
programming are we programming real
things or these ideas that we have
something else and should be trying to
turn programming into like real-world
language or should we like go the other
direction and decide maybe like that's
not the right way to do it all right and
then we still have this problem of
origin though and so you may or may not
have recognized my cows in space
painting which is a Bulls painting by
Pablo Picasso all right and I think it's
a really beautiful just artistic
rendition of what abstraction is
the fact that it's not just other thing
but it's many different layers and here
he says and this really brings that suit
some trouble there is no abstract art
you must always start with something
after that you can remove all traces of
reality and that's really what he does
in that painting but we have a question
here when we're thinking about designing
programming languages in particular as
tools for education where do we start
this start problem is a really big deal
right so I love this picture
I assume that people have seen this
before but it's a very classic one it's
the only curse word in the top unless I
mess up um so anyways yes it says how to
draw now draw some circles draw the rest
of the owl in a certain sense there's
abstractions we have in our programming
languages that do this they do it to us
and they do it to beginners and I think
we can all agree that it's pretty hard
to draw an owl with these instructions
these are really both problems
all right we're this rock and a hard
place here we know that abstraction
makes things efficient but we also know
that explicit code makes it easier to
reason about which makes it more
maintainable which in the end maybe
makes it more efficient so where do we
start what are we going to do all right
and so now I will take you on a
fantastic journey a personal voyage you
might stay with Carl Sagan where we say
that each of it begins here inside of
our head all right so the Kazon space
right we're back to this all right so
humans are beautiful pattern matchers
we're actually like just like Wonder
that's one of the best evolutionary
aspects of human beings like reading
books is actually terrible for us
there's no patterns on the page and our
short-term memory is terrible
all right but we love making and finding
patterns and so what we can do we can
look at something like this right the
sky and somehow we see this you see it
right I totally see it no anyways
someone saw it and then you got a lot of
people to agree all right and we formed
something like this when we find
patterns and we give them names we build
abstractions and that's really cool but
we need to be careful about the
abstractions that we make because these
abstractions turn into ideologies and
those ideologies are where we form our
culture in our community and so you
might end up with something like this
this is a real horoscope by the way and
maybe astrology is real because I did
rekindle my sense of inspiration on
Tuesday by dragging my travel companions
to the karaoke joint uh um so who knows
just get the hell out there we have no
idea well we do need to this in in like
Carl Sagan is like really not into it
stralla gee he calls this fuzzy thinking
and it's like we saw patterns but the
abstractions we made with those patterns
were wrong because they Timothy were
built on the wrong underlying mechanisms
all right like our personalities are not
formed by the orientation of the stars
or at least that's not something I'm
familiar with yet but we ended up with
this and people do a lot of dumb things
and spend a lot of money based on this
this is very real for people bad
abstractions are real problems all right
so let's talk about JavaScript all right
javascript has been a delightful
beginner programming language because
it's lacked a lot of abstractions that
other programming languages have we have
libraries that kind of do that for us
but JavaScript itself we have been
really baked stuff in and that's about
to change a little bit all right so
javascript was invented on September 28
1980 that is not true
just kidding this slide exists because
that is when cosmos came out and I
wanted to be on theme so it's the one a
reference I've got all right and so in
this he says this if you wish to make an
apple pie from scratch you must first
invent the universe and I was like yeah
totally
also es6 I know that was me that I'm not
him it'd be cool if I had his backing
now so yeah let's talk about es6 right
now all right
from the spec we see Eggman script
syntax is relaxed to enable it to serve
as an
you use scripting language relaxation is
awesome I have been relaxing pretty hard
this week even though even though I've
also been very nervous about my talk but
relaxing isn't like always the right
message sometimes you get something like
that so when we see that we have to
think what is the problem to be solved
here is the goal of JavaScript to be
easy to use have we asked ourselves that
what is JavaScript trying to solve
actually like what's the problem what
will be JavaScript's legacy alright
that's what that's a big question right
like when we go back in time like people
look back nematic there was once this
language called JavaScript and I'll say
this about it
and what will that be I don't know but
it probably has something to do with
this this is an excellent tweet by
Laurie vos a little while ago
he says fundamentally it is hard to
think of a compelling reason a brand new
web dev will learn two languages they
can just learn JavaScript if I could
pick any language that would work on the
client and the server it might not be
JavaScript but we don't get to pick all
right so now let's talk about es6
classes you might remember a little
robot friend here and he's warning us
about aliens all right
so sugar makes me sick like actually I
have diabetes or sugar actually makes me
sick
but syntactic sugar makes me queasy as
well and part of the reason syntactic
sugar makes me queasy is that there's
often the chance that it's obfuscating
something conceptually below it all
right and so when I see this I'm like oh
now what's going on here
alright so let's go back to the script
right even though Xmas groups includes
syntax for class definitions equi Script
objects are not fundamentally
class-based
it's like oh that's interesting how do
we do that right so you might not need
class syntax Oh anyways
this guy oh he's adorable I love this
guy he has this amazing quote he says
remember that all models are wrong the
practical question is how wrong do they
have to be do not be useful all right so
all right so how bad are we doing here
with this class in texting let's keep
reading some more spec love readings
back all right in a class-based
object-oriented language in general
state is carried by instances methods a
state is carried by instances methods
are carried by classes and in harens is
only of structure and behavior in Ekman
script the state and methods are carried
by checks
well state or structure behavior and
state are all inherited okay that's like
a lot and if you have not been reasoning
about this that might be a bit so what I
want to do is there's this guy named
Regan Wald you might know from the
internet he says cool stuff like this a
lot all right he also wrote a blog post
and I'm not going to read this to you
but what he talks about is that
prototypes are not classes what he said
is and when you're teaching classes you
often say a class is a blueprint it's a
you basically have a like a blueprint
then you can build a house from it right
your house is your object classes a
blueprint cool prototypes and like
classes in JavaScript
they aren't blueprints they're model
homes and while you might leave your
model home empty someone could also move
in and you can sleep there and so it's
actually very very different so java
classes are like kind of like objects
and then not really classes at all all
right I might be saying go home tc39
you're drunk no no that's not what I'm
saying at all this is not a hate talk
I love tc39 shout out to all the work by
everyone in open-source who does
literally anything I just want to add a
perspective and I don't want to play
down anything that people have built
because those people are awesome all
right so
so you could really shoot me down pretty
fast by being like what even is a class
and this is a good question and like
frankly the community does not have a
good ontology around what object
orientation should be nor really what
classes are at all if you're interested
in this I suggest you look this up if I
had like half more hour I would like
totally go into it but I do not but
Simula is where it started all right
what I am trying to say about JavaScript
classes and the es expect is that we're
trying to maybe do something like maybe
too many things and then we're not bound
right like we're just trying a little
too hard you can go to this place right
next to Madison Square Garden it's real
and the reason I I think about this and
this is the perspective I'm trying to
add Leslie the important is great talk
called thinking for programmers he
talked about writing a lot in he quotes
this cartoon and the cartoon says
writing is nature's way of letting you
know how sloppy your thinking is and
what I want to say is teaching is
nature's way of letting you know how
sloppy your understanding is yeah all
right
so let's get into a couple of like wings
like pretty quick I was going slow all
right so those Abel and Sussman people
they wrote this excellent tome it's
called structured interpretation of
computer programs or the sicp and this
was foundational because what it said
was we are teaching programming all
wrong we're teaching syntax we should be
teaching syntax we should be teaching
concepts and that is a big change in
like we think about javascript right now
and we're like oh oh now we have like a
syntax and that doesn't follow up with a
concept but if we should be teaching
program oh this is going to be a mess
right javascript will be the
introduction to programming concepts for
entire generation of developers whether
we like it or not that's happening all
right and so we think about the a
materials the problem being solved when
we're building these abstractions we
need to realize that one of the problems
javascript is solving is making entry
into web development significantly
easier all right so this little guy
peter van roy he's super cute he wrote
up a follow-up to the SSEP
called this GTM and he was like we need
to teach programming as a unified
discipline all right and what this means
is just programming languages are tools
and like we need to understand that they
are able to address problem and solution
pairs and those are things that we call
paradigms and some programming languages
are multi-paradigm some aren't but this
doesn't mean that there's any bad or
good language it's just a good tool for
solving a problem and he says this and
so he says a good way to organize a
programming course is to start with a
simple language and to extend that
language gradually and this is what he
calls the kernel teaching method in his
book he starts people at nothing and
then they build everything up they build
scope it's really cool and so in that
sense they're inventing their universe
their universe is a set of abstractions
they built because they felt the pain of
their absence so yeah every big inertia
reddick kernel language I mean to that
yeah just kidding us a bad idea um yeah
instead I want to take from him is the
idea of the creative extension principle
all right and what this says is again we
build the abstractions we need the ones
that we feel and in that sense we build
the universe that's most appropriate for
the problem we're trying to solve Ron
Jeffries who does XP says I think this
really well - this is not something
we've never thought about before it's
don't pre-optimized always implement
things when you actually need them never
when you just for seed that you would
need them all right so prototypical
adherence is a big part of the
JavaScript universe all right it's how
the apple pie gets made vegans yeah um
anyways so I have a summary here just
basically the slides are online and if
you want to do this but I'm saying is we
need to take an educational perspective
when we think about programming language
design because programming languages are
tools that do that and this is not just
for beginners we're all really beginners
when we're trying to reason about code
and having our abstractions match the
concepts that our language uses is going
to make it easier to reason about I want
to leave you with something more though
so I don't think we're totally lost
class is going to
javascript and that's going to be cool
but then there's going to be more specs
and I think we have a really cool
opportunity so I asked what do we even
mean when we talk about programming this
guy is Martin Heidegger I really really
like him he's one of my favorite
philosophers you wrote a book called
what is called thinking and in it he
says does the most thought-provoking
thing in our thought-provoking time is
that we are still not thinking and this
is going to sound a little kumbaya but
take it seriously
are we programming yeah like I mean it
all right there are people who are
radically redefining what it means to
program and if we understand that
programming is just abstraction like do
we need to be sitting at a terminal
typing a lot of punctuation all right
there are people who are really changing
that and I'm kind of pissed because all
those people are in grad school and I
just don't have enough money for that
and I think I think that we should be
doing it here why are we not thinking
like this alright this is Thomas Kuhn
he's a philosopher of science he wrote a
book about why I like science actually
does it make progress it's really about
just the VR taquile ssin of language set
aside he says this and this is really
important scientists work from models
acquired through education and through
subsequent exposure to literature often
without quite knowing or needing to know
what characteristics have given those
models the status of community paradigms
like why would we can do better we give
an awesome opportunity to way more
radically think about how we extend
JavaScript we don't need to join the
cool kids club like I think to a certain
extent some features are kind of like
the Abercrombie & Fitch shirt of like
language features more in middle school
like we can really really change things
alright Carl Sagan I'll end with this it
is far better to grasp the universe as
it really is than to persist in delusion
however satisfying
and reassuring so I want us to think
about our ontology think about it a lot
this is like actual work even though
it's not necessarily code and the key to
doing this is staying a beginner always
you guys are also thinking so I have one
last thing in my last four minutes and
this is a shout out again to all my
beginner students when I was a teacher
ayah they made me a website and the
website is called clap for Ashley and if
you happen to enjoy this talk or want to
see something on the screen if you tweet
with clap for Ashley down it don't hear
thank you so they don't have my network
also no one's good at flat it happens
you guys are great